come on all together now just keep
swimming just keep swimming
finding dory i was not sure what i was
gonna think about this one i on premise
it struck me as odd because finding nemo
seemed like such a complete story and
featuring
secondary characters as spin-off as
leads and spin-offs
usually doesn't work very well you can
just look at the fourth parts of the
hair being for an idea of what i'm
talking about and then the first trailer
came out in the first trailer really
just made it look like they made finding
nemo again except they have to rescue
dory instead of nemo so i was really
kind of nervous going into this i didn't
have to be though it's good it's solid i
do think it's getting a bit over praised
right now you look at it's rotten
tomatoes percentage and it's like it's
in the 90s and people you know they're
going oh it's amazing it's good it is
good pixar it's not quite at the level
some people are saying that it is but
you know what we'll get to nitpicks in a
bit let's start with what's good well
dory's good dory remains good they they
manage to circumvent a lot of the
problems that usually happens when you
take a side character and make them the
main character because they get her into
some really good relationships with
other characters mostly with hank the
octopus and the two of them work really
well as a double act it lends itself to
a lot of physical comedy with the way
that hank moves and having him be able
to move her around um this sort of
aquarium facility where she's looking to
her parents solves a lot of the
logistical problems of how do you get a
fish around a place that was built to
allow for people to move not for fish to
be able to get from one place to another
returning characters work well there are
some really good new characters like i
said hankies kind of the highlight
there's some other nice ones as well
there's a lot of really sweet moments
particularly uh in regards to some of
the flashbacks we get with dory's
parents and you know what if you're i
don't know how kids are gonna respond on
this level but certainly if you're an
adult and if you're adult with kids yeah
it's gonna hit you right there as pixar
has a tendency to do we should be used
to that part by now the humeral works
very well a surprising amount of it
actually does not depend on dory's
short-term memory loss i mean that's
still a thing but it's actually now more
of plot function than it is a running
joke because the fact that she can't
remember things is a big obstacle to her
trying to find her parents and so it
becomes a hurdle and her sort of working
around this disability that she's got i
actually i don't know if it was
intentional but i feel like working
around and coping with disability is
kind of a running theme of this
particular film arguably it was in nemo
as well but i think it's it's really big
here because you've got dory nemo's
still there with his wonky finn hank is
missing a tentacle there's other
characters like destiny and becky and
there's this beluga whale whose name i
forget there's a lot of characters with
some form of disability something that
is holding them back that they have to
find a way to work around and i don't
think it's a message that necessarily
bangs you over the head with it but it
does seem to be running through the film
and i think that's kind of interesting
now as i said there are some nitpicky
things there are some things holding
this back honestly i kind of wonder if
nemo and marlon should have been in this
really at all past maybe the opening
segment and then again at the end them
trying to find dory as dory is also
trying to find her parents i'm not sure
that really works they feel tacked on
they feel like they're there to to pad
the run time a bit and give us a break
from dory now finding a way to give us a
break from dory is probably necessary to
keep her from becoming annoying which
she could have if she appeared too
frequently but nothing that they do it
really moves the plot forward anyway
they're just always several steps behind
her and another thing and this is a
general thing that it's it's hard for me
to quite pin down and articulate but
i'll try it feels like they tried to
reverse engineer
uh some of what worked in finding nemo
because a big part of what worked about
finding nemo is it kind of had that road
trip feel where they encounter these
various odd characters as they go along
but the way it felt in finding nemo was
they had the story and you know we got
to get them from a to b they'll run into
these obstacles and they looked at okay
what's the opportunities for what
interesting characters that we can have
them run into along the way and so you
get the sharks you get the school of
fish that do the charades thing you get
nigel the pelican you get the fish tank
gang and all that it feels like a little
bit in this one that they came up with
all the characters that they wanted
dory and the others to interact with and
then
figured out a way to get them in later
well some of them are very organic and
work i mentioned hank he's fine destiny
and the beluga whale are okay but then
there's others like the seals that just
keep showing up and they're not bad but
i don't understand why we're lingering
on them as much and it feels like they
went oh we came up with these sealed
characters let's get them in there when
that they're not as organic but of
course that's uh that these are nitpicky
adult watching kids entertainment things
if you have kids your kids are gonna
love this they're gonna have a great
time there's some great slapstick it
moves well a lot of most of the
characters are funny and work it's sweet
it's touching this is not some of
pixar's best but it is pixar just
working like clockwork they know how to
do this stuff and they do it well and it
works so that's my thoughts on finding
dory have you seen it what were your
thoughts on it whatever they were drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it please don't forget to
like subscribe follow me on twitter
council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcast on itunes and stitcher
and as for me i will be back as soon as
i can get my next fix
[Applause]
you